viggo vents his anger and he kicks the
helmet across the landscape
and i said to viggo you know i'm going
to put the camera down the hillside a
little bit and can you try to kick the
helmet as close as possible to the lens
because it'll look great if it just like
flies past us so as key grip i was
standing right next to the camera
it comes within a hairs distance of my
body peter he is clearly aiming at me
and then i thought oh look he's got
better each time if i just give him one
more take
wherever i move
uh somehow
viggo is able to kick directly at me no
don't get
you are aiming i know you can aim the
fourth take i thought was really good i
thought well that's pretty close i don't
know
if he was having a bad day if i and he
didn't say anything to us but we found
out that viggo had actually broken
two toes with that last kick oh vigo he
got hurt during the poor vigo
okay he broke his his toes will you look
at me viggo vigo
vigo no peter he needs to hear this i
told peter i can't work under these
conditions i i can't
it's either viggo or me he can't have
both
he fired me within the hour
[Music]
you